folks Joe and Sal here from the taste
buds podcast we are doing our very first
live live stream at episode live stream
episode when made
maybe sale there's gonna be a ton of
surprises there's gonna be guests
there's gonna be a Premiere that night
of should we tease it not yet okay not
yet it's a big something yeah something
very big we've been teasing it for a
while it's coming finally the live
stream May 10th also merch is still
available for the taste buds podcast go
and get you some uh it's available at my
website jodarosainfo.com or
salvocanocomedy.com and also we are both
on the road doing live dates we've got
tons we've only got time to name a few I
next coming up will be in Michigan in
several cities uh and then also in
Illinois for several cities and in New
York at the crane theater anyway just
check out my website joeinfo.com for all
the info on that plus Joey Rose's
Remington Street Manhattan Joey get a
sandwich affordable great sandwiches and
drinks I'm on the road with the guys uh
this is our first tour since before the
pandemic our fifth International tour
tickets are on sale right now and
impracticaljokerslive.com there's tons
of cities and tons more will be added
next up March 24th in Green Bay the 25th
of Milwaukee the 26th in Rosemont then
we're going to Seattle and Portland in
April as well as Bangor Maine and Boston
again and then later on so forth it's a
lot of Ohio a lot of Texas uh two in St
Louis and practicaljokerslive.com brand
new episodes of Impractical Jokers every
Thursday night at 10 o'clock on TBS and
True TV season 10 out right now taste
buds they come into the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two Fool's gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the freezing pimps rolling rolling
rolling
[Applause]
it's immediately freezing
Sal's having hot flashes he keeps asking
us to open this door and then we open
the windows it's very cold
by the way shout outs to the new studio
very nice like it's gonna build from
here but yes uh and I have merch for you
I never got to this okay let's do this
yeah shout outs pimpy got this done so
this is for you from Hornswoggle he he
sent me more shirts a dick on a DM
recently well they sent us things like
you dick and I was like I I saw it like
because I don't check him a lot I saw it
like a month later I was like oh [__]
what did I do and he just wrote back I
was just probably drunk
he when when we exchanged numbers he
said to me I hope you're ready for drunk
face times because you're getting them
and he has delivered on that shout out
to I guess shout out to Dylan uh but uh
this is a t-shirt he sent us it's him
with no pants on I guess
I mean not I guess that's what it is
great
uh guess again close uh that's funny
it's really funny yeah I'll [__] rock
that he said the ones I gave you already
he was like that that they were the
wrong shirts of the gym remember I
brought shirts on and I said these were
from him and they were shirts and I
asked you if he was an investor right
investor in the gym or something because
I didn't understand it because neither
of us did I'm just going to toss this
over there no disrespect actually I'll
put it back in the box
and then see this kid's sea Lance who's
A hip-hop producer sea Lance yeah that's
his name that's not his god-given name
that's not his Christian name okay yeah
uh thank God you told me uh he sent us
some stuff I actually know his work from
before I've met him at shows
uh so he sent us two very cool t-shirts
these are both Heroes no they're
different designs they're like
definitely like Street Wear kind of
like you know kind of wild like skate
shop
designs almost
that one's my favorite the brain melting
Beats and this one is the cover of this
album that he's or an alternate cover of
this album
yeah it's wild right
hip-hop so
this has a metal Edge yeah
thank you so he sent us each a copy of
his new vinyl
and he autographed both of ours yours is
autographed too this is yours uh but
this is really cool he's got he's a
producer he's got apathy on here Vinnie
Paz esoteric from zarface shout outs
esoteric oh yeah my boy uh oh yeah yeah
boys with him right yeah he's got
evidence on here
actually yeah we should have him on
taste buds
esoteric you should do taste buds oh he
was gonna come to the one on yeah Dylan
you should do taste buds everybody sea
Lance come do taste buds now I feel bad
we didn't invite sea lands if you're
watching please be us uh
uh ill bills on here sick Jack in mad
child this is like a lot of really
really cool uh
dark underground yeah yeah sorry the
rugged Man Murs like this is this is
cool that's awesome really cool and he
does good stuff he gave me he gave me
something a long time I think there's a
CD it was really good you know what a
record is a
thank God anyway I would have jumped out
the window there you go thank you thank
you well don't thank me by all means
send gifts we'll turn this into an
unboxing podcast can we please get a PO
Box though because they come to the bar
we got one
because things come to the bar and then
the bartenders put them somewhere and
then I have to go dig into these like
tiny closets to figure out what it is
and then I have it nobody wants that and
then I sense I like that secret and I
say hey I got this stuff here should I
bring it and then he doesn't respond uh
and then I'm walking around the city
with a box full of stuff
um you said send me send me something
and it reminded me this song you send me
no no oh that's a good one that's an old
school Send Me an Angel
Send Me an Angel
it's 80s and it's famously attached to a
movie that is not a huge movie but it
was for us at that time Jewel of the
Nile no starring Kathleen Turner that's
not that's that's and you don't mention
Michael Douglas
to me she was always the star I love
that no no I watched that Michael Dougs
and Danny DeVito yeah wait you watch Joe
the Nile not Romancing the Stone oh I
watch romance that's the original yeah
retro Manson yeah no but I know Julie so
here's what so do you do you have any
idea do you want to take a guess I mean
you're not give me a hint
um okay it was more geared toward young
people in the movie
it was it was okay okay give me a hand
um
it had
you would call this a sport in a way
it was geared toward young people and it
was very 80s this this this this this
this this this hobby this is red yes oh
wow
wow I didn't I've never seen red but I
hear it's like legendarily one of the
worst movies ever made yeah but it's
good it's bad though but it's good
that's the theme that's that
that's the main theme song you've never
seen it yeah would you pull that out of
your ass because you when you said it's
sports like I was like all right this is
either like
one of those kind of things Gleaming the
Cube early Christmas yeah yeah yeah yeah
you you have a good good knowledge up
there some some call me a cinema
are you would you call yourself a cinema
no I would say I'm a very casual one if
I may you know but I do see a decent
amount of you're on are you a cinephile
were you more cinephile or an audiophile
you know with both I'm very focused on
Dad
with both I'm focused on very particular
I'm a mediafile I love purchasing
physical media okay but I'm very focused
on specific things genres and with it so
like my movie collection for the most
part is hard you're a sandwich file too
sandwich file yeah but only certain
types of sandwiches
a bond me can take a walk yeah okay take
a walk you don't like the Vietnamese as
people no okay
I love the Vietnamese people uh that
sandwich I don't like because I don't
like the there's just something about
the combination of flavors it doesn't I
don't I don't upon me
upon you on you Dad yeah
no but I like specific genres so it's
like it's like I love like my movie
collection is mostly horror yes I know
this my music collection I have more
hip-hop than anything else you have
given me
two requests to watch movies that I
thought were not good
suggestions yeah I'm sorry suggestions
when I asked you for a good horror movie
you now now this might be because you
are entrenched in that world I mean
there's some things that mean more to
you than they would to the average
person right but I thought I see I see
what you meant but you know you know
when you you know when you love
something and and you show it to someone
new and it doesn't hold up but they
don't have the experience of watching it
when it came out and when it was more
relatable and applicable and of the
times and you take that Nostalgia with
you and you love it because when you
watch it you know how you felt the first
time you watched but then you asked
someone else to watch it and it's a 30
year old movie they're like I don't get
it yeah definitely the case of course
but I'll tell you too off the top that I
remember because I was like Joe one you
were with me for I know you're talking
about the infamous cat's eye view yes
a man had space already because it was
like the fifth movie we tried to what
was it we shut it Stephen King It was
there was so much debate on what to
watch it was ridiculous
it was like watching molasses you guys
you guys turned to me and said what's a
fun horror movie we can watch is it cat
size a lot of fun but it wasn't fun it
is when you don't spend 48 minutes
turning on other movies and stopping
them and then you know but it's come on
I I didn't stand a chance in hell uh
another friend of mine you got to read
the room man that that was a slow that
was not fun do you remember what it was
pitted up against yeah another friend of
ours recommended a Spanish-speaking art
film by the way that was Argentinian by
the way I watch it it's one of my
all-time favorite movies well you think
that moment was the time we missed the
boat so bad on Washington I've doubled
back and told big J he has to watch it I
bought it and I've since watched it five
times I'm not kidding five times I've
watched it and I've told about 20 people
about it they were right right it's
called wild Tales it's an Argentinian
film it is gangbusters you thought that
that was the time to watch your
subtitles wild Tales it makes the cat's
eye look like a piece of [__] look cat's
eye is not you know it's not gonna win
any awards what is it about what is it
about cats it's an anthology movie
Stephen King wrote all the stories each
story involves a cat in some way shape
or form and that's a hard it's a
horrible up
foreign
this particular one was about the cat's
eye quitters Inc awesome Stephen King's
Story
uh
uh uh the the ledge or whatever the hell
is called awesome stuff six seven eight
of us and we were just like
like waiting don't get me started on the
taste of the group of people that was in
that room fine don't get me started let
me take you over to the other one you
recommended to me okay is it it's not
Jacob's Ladder because that's a famous
One Jacob's letter is amazing yeah no
it's not chicken yes that's old right
Jacob's Ladder there was a remake that
was not good but yes okay timoth Timothy
Tim Robbins amazing okay so not that but
for some reason that's the name I'm
getting in my head Jacob's Ladder I
don't know Jacob was in it you told me
to watch it it was a horror movie
yeah you said it was good you told me to
watch it on uh
the streaming service to horror movie
Shutter yeah and I and we mean we put it
on uh me and my old lady and uh we were
like is he serious you've got a movie
with you've got no plot right now you've
got no title but and you're in fact
giving me the title of a new movie that
you're not talking about but think about
it was so was did you tell me to watch
Jacob's Ladder remake
it was two words and a guy's name was in
the title come on Joey never tell you to
watch that Jacob's Ladder no no no but
babe and are you sure isn't that are you
sure it's not a movie Jay suggested
because Jay has suggested uh what are we
gonna do uh
Jay suggested a movie to me on shutter
recently that had a guy's name in the
title that I texted him and I go you
this movie sucks dude it's so boring was
it the movie with Nick Stahl I don't
know that's but listen to me think about
it was the Terminator in it the the man
down no no no no no no all right but can
you just just we'll move on but can you
just do what you did access what you got
rad from until it's a guy's name and I
think it's it's about bro I don't have a
horror movie with a guy's name and a
title and it was about two words and it
was it was during the pandemic maybe it
was a few years old
you how do you not know I don't know
what it's you're talking about and I'm
you're not even sure it was you
suggested I'm pause I just said you sure
it wasn't Jay that said no and I pointed
right at you oh okay
you you you you you suggested it buddy
you got to give me some kind of plot
point something
it's a guy scary
it was it was it it was weird give you
that who's in it anything no one I ever
heard of
all right all right well I I don't know
you thought you thought the Halloween
was good and I believe you thought
Halloween kills was passed last
Halloween was the worst movie I've ever
seen the Halloween before that was good
no it wasn't Halloween kills is one of
the worst horror movies ever made not
this last Halloween no I know Halloween
ends not evil dies tonight that was the
worst one that's Halloween kills
Halloween ends before that the one
before that sucked too but not as no the
new one I didn't even bother because
evil dies tonight was so bad I said
never again the one before that I was
pleasantly surprised I was like that was
a really good movie so you think that
the good movies are not good and you
think would you think of evil lies
tonight it was terrible okay it was
terrible I could pick that movie we
probably didn't see how the untrained
mind would think the new Halloween was
good somebody like you
but once someone that has a bit of
knowledge and a tastes about watching
scariness it just was a lot of kills it
was a lot of gratuitous kills like there
was it was it was they were they every
plot point of it was done better in a
previous Halloween movie like it just
wasn't good I'm saying that they went on
a streak of not good ones and then that
was like a refreshing one I disagree I
think there were several that were much
much better in the beginning but then
they had a string of like no I'm talking
about the one prior to that one yes yes
all right I'm over this yes oh I'm sorry
are you want to come in here dismantle
my [__] judgmentation in cinema I
wish I could remember this horror movie
I really don't look in all fairness I'm
going to just suggested some of you
because you asked and I was like uh I
don't know I just watched this it was
okay
it might have been one of those Oh I
thought you had something on the to say
no I'm saying the one I can't remember I
might have very well Cat's Eye I'm not
gonna lie to you not in a million years
would have been my first pick to bring
to the table let's watch this there was
so much pressure and so much tension in
that room we started and stopped talking
about mom like I said if there was eight
of us seven people well like
the room was getting tense we were
socially hanging out how quickly did the
room turn on him
15 minutes no we got at five people's
eyes started going like this to each
other at 10 and then I and then we
should shut it we just outright shut it
we and then and then there was no no
people were like Joe what the [__] just
shut it we went about 45 minutes into it
yeah and it's painful and then we let
somebody else pick and then we let
somebody else pick a movie and that was
bad bombed worse than cats yeah it was a
bad night nobody had the juju that night
yeah but we should have watched wild
Tales you guys would love this movie
dude it's it's it's five or six short
stories in a movie all stand alone and
that's why I suggests a cat's eye
because the person that suggested wild
tales and we all made fun of them don't
read anything about wild Tales we all
made fun of them for suggesting it
because I heard a bunch of short stories
right now things and I was like that's
not the vibe she said short stories and
I said oh I uh the Cat's Eye short
stories you know dude I swear to God I
actually want to watch while I enjoy
I've watched it five times because I've
watched it three and I had like two or
three times I've I've said to someone in
my house you're gonna love this movie
while watching it and I put it on and I
watched it in real time for the third
floor just because I like to see people
watch it that's how good it is yeah it's
a good it's fascinating
and I would I would I would love you
guys to watch it and then tell me what
you thought about it it's like it's very
original
well I mean yeah you know what Sergeant
Tina made four movies oh this guy this
guy's got the goods I'm telling you no I
hear it's great I just it wasn't the
time for it that night and it was funny
to make fun of somebody I suggested we
watch a subtitles
The Iron is we put on cat's eye and we
didn't listen to them
don't get me you know how much I love
this movie
I watch it two days in a row
that's how much I love the movie I stand
by it well listen I want to I'd like to
see it you know I think it's a good idea
my I never said
no I think you should leave
oh yes that is from that that's a great
show
by the way the person that asked me to
suggest the movie and said let's go with
cat sorry
is the person I'm friends with that
always is asking me about horror movies
and and whatever so I was a little
pushed into that okay
so all right well we don't need to bring
any tension to it no there's tension now
yeah I mean there's a level of judgment
here you scorned now there's a lot of
there's women sad when they when they
shut off his film was he upset in the
room I think he was trying to defend it
and be like you're not watching it the
right way you're not giving it a chance
and but then people just started like
making fun of it and stuff let's also
not let's also take an account everybody
in the room except me was high on on
grass
yeah that couldn't have had anything to
do with it
Cordoba boom
oh that's right I forgot what could I
was trying to remember what Qdoba boom
my favorite quarter of the entire
podcast we need a Qdoba boom shirt V
to what you flippantly said it like it
was dead to rights mic drop Cordova boom
I couldn't remember what I'm doing was I
was playing yeah yeah I said name
another person no I remember I remember
boom now I kept talking
uh grass was a choice you made yes of
course but you guys were all high out of
your minds I mean you know that's I
think it was just normal high I think we
smoked a drink
well you know just it's it's just just
that sweater Gramps why
I'm just saying you're calling the grass
you're saying we're higher out of our
minds you know you know well all right
you know uh you showed me a piece of art
when I'm when I'm [__] canned and I'll
I'll give you a fair assessment of it
come on all right that's all I'm saying
you know that's all what drug did you do
that you don't know is it was it weed
that I got you to smoke and then you
went up in the my spare bedroom went to
bed for about two three hours there was
two times it was one time no don't wait
don't say it if it's not weed it's not
me
whether or not we
[Laughter]
weeds at Ari's place and both times I
had to go in the other room and lay by
myself now here's the funniest one uh
the one at already heroin
it was I'll say and beep it right yeah
no no you could say Mushrooms yeah it's
fine I told this story without naming
anybody's names except Ari I did not
name your name but now it's out now I
can actually tell the story uh I told
the story I didn't take mushrooms at
Ari's house
what's called mushrooms okay
[Laughter]
we took I went into the bedroom and I
was I was freaking out like and you guys
were blaring
blaring uh Popeye
cartoons oh it was so loud if you ever
go back and watch the initial pop you
know papayas thank God you ever go watch
the original cartoons wild stuff man
wild I mean it wouldn't be it was like
some of it was insanely racist and out
of pocket and you're just like I cannot
believe well we put it on just to like
oh cool like I wonder what the old
episodes like and we put it on we were
just like see they got it on dude it is
so loud I'm laying in the bedroom I'm
already freaking out and it's so loud
I'm like
it's not that loud it's not that loud
you're just freaking out you're just
freaking out you're just calm down to my
actual bedroom not even my spare no I
went into my bedroom yes my bed yes
uh this wasn't that this was at Ari's
old apartment you just laid on your
business I did this and this time I was
on Ari's bed doing that and I'm like
please don't freak out don't freak out
don't freak out dude it's not that loud
it's not you're just freaking out
why was the loud cartoon bothering you
that in that way just because you were
all kept explaining that's what I'm
saying I'm like it was like I was like
it was I was like this just can't be
this loud I I'm bugging out like I think
that this is way too loud because I'm
just freaking out okay
and like
what seemed like 40 minutes in your
lifetime you will tell someone in
seriousness to get off your lawn
continue
hold on before you judge before you
judge
uh would seem like about 40 minutes had
gone by and I'm like trying to talk
myself out of it the door to the bedroom
opens Justin silver walks in
he goes
dude can I lay with you in here they're
playing Popeye way too loud out there
who's too much
where are we going with this app today
nerds versus uh gummy bears okay all
right let's uh we should get into it man
yeah
oh I just got anxiety thinking about
drugs
oh God it gives me such anxiety
right now that's crazy yeah
yeah anyway
uh
all right we gotta get about like you
doing drugs or [__] or the potential
solution have you done hallucinogenics
we just talked about it oh is it
mushroom a hallucinogenic I didn't
hallucinate it yeah weed uh mush you
know mushrooms acid Molly like I said I
would never do that I did I used to love
it I used to love going to like another
planet maybe that's what maybe that's
what got you here
you of all people you don't like to
smoke marijuana you did acid I used to
love weed I used to smoke weed every day
wow smoke weed everyday something in my
head like broke where it was like dude
this is it was I told I I repeatedly
said this it was something during
lockdown
it was like some during lockdown like I
was like I can't even kind of smoke weed
anymore like it's yeah you want to open
that that [__] and that's the last
time I ever did Molly was locked down
last time I ever did mushrooms was
locked down I was like that's it I'm
done they're gone from my life I can't
anything
and so you got anxiety thinking about
the trip
the previous if I just think about it I
start to get anxiety it gives me crazy
oh my God especially now with like the
bar and all this other stuff I would
have a panic attack sometimes I smoke
weed and I get because I don't really do
it a lot now and I don't do a lot of it
and I never really get high it's just
more relaxing but the times when I have
taken so much weed that I run I run all
the characteristics I'm paranoid I
literally can't understand in my own
mind how I'm a comic like how I'm gonna
go do my next show get up on stage to
people I don't know where the microphone
tell these Jokes which probably aren't
funny which I'm not funny I'm not funny
I'm never gonna do this I'll never be
able to do it again I did it it was fine
I'll never be able to recreate it and I
get so in my head it just about stand up
and it it's a real feeling too it's hard
I've been doing standing forever it's a
real feeling I'm like I don't know how
I'm gonna do it next time I don't feel
like people say like an imposter
syndrome or something like I'm just like
I'm so afraid to get on stage I have
nothing to say that's funny and people
will say people will say like oh dude
you just got to remind yourself you're
just high and it's like that's not how
it works man yeah like your brain
doesn't work that way when your brain is
reacting poorly to a drug it is not able
to say I'm just this well I'll tell you
that unless without like some real
guidance like that's why they have those
guided like sure well those things no
never but I will but after that happened
to me a few times I would say to myself
you did it you thought this last time
and you did it so just stop thinking
about it you know what I mean alcohol is
literally the only drug
where I am able to handle what it is
doing to me in real time
and I don't freak out and maybe that's
only a matter of time but like it's the
only thing where even if I get too drunk
I'm able to say I'm too drunk right I
know what I am right now I cannot do
that with any other kind of drug dude
even I'm talking even painkillers that
my doctor has given me yeah like when I
bruised a rib and he gave me not the bad
oxy the one that's like less bad there's
like Oxycontin and oxycodone or whatever
none of them are great but the point is
like there's the one that's like not
quite as horrible he gave me the Lesser
one and I took it once and I was like
[__] this dude like I had to go lay down
I couldn't like I was like I can't
anything that alters my state that
drastically and that quickly I can't do
it I cannot do it anymore well I
remember you also talked about that bad
trip you had which I don't know if Sal
knows about but he you want a really bad
mushroom trip and you had to leave a
movie right I told that whole it's too
long of a story to tell right now but I
told that entire story on Craig
kilbourne's radio show or I'm sorry
Craig Ferguson's radio show
and Craig Ferguson had me me and this
guy Joe who's to co-host the show with
him he had us write a screenplay of it
no [__] he was like that's a really
great Ferguson a good dude he seems the
best and he seems like a really good
dude I hear that he has a his reputation
is that he's a really great he's the
best guy on Earth yeah where is he now
he
I don't I don't know if it's
he moved I don't know if it's private or
not so I don't I won't say where but
like he's doing yeah he's hosting he's
hosting some new game show and he's he's
Charming he just announced his new tour
he's Charming right extremely no but you
can pick it up right away you can watch
one minute dude he had me he invited me
to his Christmas party
we he's a guy I met him we just we just
hit it off we just hit easy to talk to
them the best and he's he's sober and
he's publicly sober and he liked he
liked that I he liked hearing me tell
drinking stories and then like just hit
it off man and um
I remember he invited me to his
Christmas party and his Christmas party
was like a who's that his house yeah
okay the first time he threw it or he
has an annual he has this big annual
thing he does he's known for it yeah and
he invited me it was at his house and
dude
no no have a party iPod
DJ
I don't know Sal I don't know I'm trying
to set the tone in my head I mean you
know it's a party
but you could give me a little more than
that well I'm trying to use it I'm
trying to you're you're asking me
questions let me get to it no food the
whole nine booze whatever you know uh
are you dressed up
there's a Christmas party right that's
why I ask was it like slightly more
formal than the normal we wore a sweater
no it was just a Christmas party it was
just a fun place in New York then it was
in L.A it was in L.A big big spot big
pad yes he's got cash that guy
he's banked a lot of it from that show
he's got a lot it was late it was legit
it was on Drew Carey I forgot yeah sure
anyway I show up to his Christmas party
he greeted me ballet
dude I I don't like when you do this I
hate it I hate when you do this it's
like when he kept singing after
everything I said
I don't really like that put
I don't care for this but this one I'm
not really making a joke I just love to
I love the details I don't remember it
was a house party
for his friends all right it'll be less
interesting to the list it's not if you
let me get to the part I'm trying to
tell you
he greeted me with all this wonderful
sincerity that he would greet any it was
really sweet he was like a guy who's
like truly happy you came like literally
like dude you made it that's so great it
was really nice I walk in first person I
see is Kristen Shaw who I've known for a
long time sure I go up I start talking
to her
she's like do you guys know Joe I turned
first guy I beat ready he's like Hey Joe
I'm Al Weird Al Yankovic no this is no
way I know you want to dick around with
with valet bits right I'm trying to get
you the good stuff because I went to it
because I went to a Christmas party from
for Seth MacFarlane right and it was
this huge event he throws every year and
it was over the top crazy I think I've
talked about it before and it was valet
I just was trying to liken it to the
party probably valet I don't remember
all right I ubered because I knew I was
gonna have a few pops as did I yeah uh
Weird Al first guy I meet yeah I leave
the living room to walk through the
foyer into the kitchen as I'm walking
through the foyer who do I see sitting
on the stairs Mick Jagger Shirley Manson
from garbage
you recognized her as such yeah
immediately sure I was like that's the
chick from garbage yeah holy [__] I walk
into the kitchen to get a drink
you ready for this you ready for this is
what a weird collection of people you
ready for this yeah Larry King sitting
at the kitchen table that was the last
name I thought you'd say that was that
was the last name I thought you'd say
full by the way Larry King a Pebbles
throw away from Shirley Manson by the
way full suspenders apparently just the
shoulders Larry King all the time yeah
yeah and I was like did you talk to him
I met him I shook his hand and I I was
very very briefly he's going to
Christmas parties what year was this and
then I went outside because I was a
little like holy [__] this place is as
Neil Brennan once said to me at an SNL
party and it made me laugh really hard
he goes this place is lousy with
celebrities
I was like there's too many celebrities
in here I gotta go outside I'm like a
little freaked out because I was like
especially if I'm gonna have a
drinks was outside and I just and I know
Greg and I just hung out with Greg
proofs okay
Glazer and tone Bell showed up
eventually
it was uh they were the two people I
like knew uh it was you know it was like
2016 or something wow
maybe maybe 17. so what what was the
most of like a memorable thing that was
it just was it just a great party social
fun lash drinks leave or did anything
memorable happen that you'll be like oh
man this this was the story to tell this
happened no story Weird Al Yankovic play
a song or no no nothing like that I went
to a different party I'll tell you you
know Weird Al Yankovic is okay I'll tell
you a different party I went to yeah in
L.A this was the craziest party I've
ever been to in La Burr brought me
bird brought me to Bob Saget's 60th
birthday party
it was at the house of the guy who
created Full House
it was at his house okay his house
I've never seen anything like it in my
life
Yes Yes actually yeah I've never seen
anything like it in my life it was a
monstrosity like it was that's probably
a negative word but I mean it was just
it looked like a [__] Castle it was
crazy it was crazy yeah and uh Network
smash hit sitcom yeah one part at one
point I don't think I'm talking out of
school here burp we were outside look at
that spur goes this place looks like a
cheesecake fact
it was so excited
so big and like every single place you
went in this project
he's friends with saggins we we went
dude every single place you went in this
party dude it was I was I was bugging
did you have free roam yeah it was just
a regular old house party McFarland had
like areas cut off that you couldn't go
to oh no this I mean it wasn't like you
could go upstairs but it was like yeah
it was like he was like here's the party
like it was it was like a normal house
party yeah this thing was not normal
actually he this was an event he had a
he had a an orchestra okay so here's
what happens right yeah I'm I'm not
kidding dude I'm we're going we're gonna
go around the room I'm in one room I
look over
John Stamos and the Full House girls are
standing there and I was literally
called that is crazy
I'm trying not to look yeah we go
outside we sit by the pool half of the
guy named Gibbler there yeah it was her
Cameron oh no no not kid no no I'm sorry
not get no no I'm sorry okay it was the
two older sisters you must hate being
called but how do you not it was the two
older sisters yeah and uh and and Stamos
and I think Julie two older sisters yeah
Jody Sweden is so hot
I was like holy well did she augment
herself yeah full blouse
talk about it talk about twins that were
on the show yeah yeah
[Laughter]
we go outside we sit by the pool
standing right did you augment yeah
half of the guys from Entourage are
sitting by the pool no way it's like
you're walking from real movie scene to
real real TV scenes a real TV scene
ready for this yeah
we go then to the yard
Norman Lear
Norman Lear that's that's sitting there
like just like that says you go to
parties with a 95 plus year old people
it was that's two different parties that
a 95 year old was that so then dude I
sit down to eat I sit down Norman Lear
the creator of I mean The Jeffersons on
the family everything you could think of
orally is there right I sit down to eat
I'm at a table with thank God
and I don't even know him that well for
[__] Seth Green
I met him two times ever on opium I sat
at a table it's like there's like it's
like Jimmy Kimmel it's it's just all I
can't remember everybody everybody at
the table is famous and I'm just like
I'm so [__] uncomfortable I'm just so
uncomfortable and Seth Green sat next to
me with his wife his wife is really
lovely and I've met her a couple times
now too
and we start I was like Hey dude I don't
know if you remember we were on
and he's like yeah oh yeah this is my
wife and I go Seth told me how he met
you you were dressed like Han Solo at a
at a Comic-Con and she's like oh my yeah
and I was like and we just started
talking about like comic book [__] and I
was like thank God for this guy like
he's like just letting me be normal you
know and uh
and it was wild
The Beach Boys get up and play in the
living room in the living room Brian
Wilson no now the the worst Beach Boys
okay
but still it's still the Beach Boys
they're playing in the living room they
played in the living room I remember I
had to leave to go do it so that's the
thing I was asking about the other part
I was I and the the the elite and I
don't say this to this marriage he's a
friend of mine he's a good friend of
mine the least famous person there was
the guy I clung onto and hung out with
because we're buddies was Tom Green Tom
Green was the least famous person there
he was
even Williams oh
I just said two yeah like the same
bucket for me and we all had spots at
The Improv later and I remember like I
left and I saw them down the improvs and
we were all I remember Tom was like that
was a wild party huh you left that party
for spots I went and did a spot at the
Improv yeah I wanted to leave dude yeah
yeah two hours of that goes
yeah yeah it was it was a little too
much but but uh it was speaking of
sensory overload nerds are we are we
like at time
okay
nerds yeah well I see one two three in
this room
and that's what I'm gonna beat you I'm
gonna beat you 75 to 25 it's gummy bear
versus
nerds for you know we
have budge chant on the last episode we
did uh it's nerds versus gummy bears
today folks do you wanna do you need a
salty I mean I don't know I don't know I
don't think I need it okay ready yeah
time four
b-a-t-t-l-e butts all right the uh Pim
can you do an edit on those did you ever
done this where it goes
on each letter camera camera camera
camera camera yeah
let's do it I want to see what it looks
like yeah yeah I want to see how crazy
it looks all right all right cool the uh
thank you not that's the only time I'm
overdo an edit request can I just unless
it's cut something guys as a parent your
top priority is always your children's
well-being I hope you want to give them
everything they need to grow and to
thrive both now and in the future and
with term life insurance from fabric by
Gerber Life help protect your family so
their future is secure no matter what
happens if you're looking to organize
your financial future make sure to start
with life insurance fabric by Gerber
Life provides an easy One-Stop shop for
all your family's financial needs
offering high quality term life
insurance policies plus other Financial
Solutions in one easy online Hub fabric
was designed by parents for parents to
help you get high quality surprisingly
affordable term life insurance policy in
less than 10 minutes you could be
offered coverage instantly with no
Health exam required fabric has a 30-day
money-back guarantee and you can cancel
at any time so protect your family today
with fabric by Gerber Life apply today
in just 10 minutes at meatfabric.com
taste buds that's
meatfabric.com tastebuds meat being
m-e-e-t fabric.com
policies issued by Western Southern life
Assurance company not available in
certain States prices subject to
underwriting and health questions
guys premium meals don't have to come at
a premium price butcher box provides you
with the best meat and seafood on the
planet so that you can whip up quality
meals on your budget guys premium meals
don't have to come at a premium price
butcher box provides you with the best
meat and seafood on the planet so you
can whip up quality meals on your budget
okay peace of mind with butcher box
easily find high quality Meat and
seafood you can trust 100 grass-fed beef
free-range organic chicken pork raised
crate free and wild caught Seafood
humanely raised no antibiotics or added
hormones let's talk about convenience
it's delivered right to your doorstep
there's free shipping always you can
curate the boxes to customize your needs
or get a pre-planned box the value a
variety of high quality cuts at a really
amazing value exclusive member deals
recipe inspiration guides tips and hacks
I mean really they can't make it easier
for you get free
chicken nuggets for a year
and 10 percent off your first box when
you sign up today
that is a deal that's a 22 ounce bag of
gluten-free chicken nuggets in every
order for one year when you sign up at
butcherbox.com tastebuds and use the
code taste buds claim the deal at
code taste buds
we're right in it we're right in it but
you just reminded of something I thought
was insane about 20 plus years ago I did
a short film and it took place in a
Mexican restaurant and um we gave it to
a friend of ours to do some editing and
it was taking a long time and we got it
back and we're like what in the world
could have taken like this much time
like it was just like it wasn't that you
know even a first string out right and
we got it back and unbeknownst to us at
one point I don't know why but I I in
the scene I'm saying something and I
like literally like bang the table or
something like that and there's chips
and salsa on the table and he's CGI
chips popping out of the thing and
falling onto the table
and it looked like CGI you know I mean
he did it at home I don't know how he
did it but I was like I cannot believe
that he just voluntarily took the time
to put in CGI of tortilla chips just
just falling off a basket like it was so
unnecessary and then it was in it was in
the cut like we couldn't be like
on CGI that's so funny I mean also I had
no idea he had a skill set like that
yeah I remember uh by the way
I remember going to a Fourth of July
picnic at Burr's house
after we went to that party
and it was me Burr his wife his
mother-in-law and Jordan Peele and
Chelsea Peretti and
and Burr started to deal with that birth
because he was married yeah it was like
when he was like just got married to
Chelsea Peretti okay uh and yeah so
actually and at that barbecue I go what
are you up to and he goes I just
directed a horror movie man I was like
oh congrats on the planet yeah anyway uh
he uh bird made fun of me about
something regarding that party
and I go I remember I go uh I go yeah no
it was a hell of a party Bill thanks for
bringing me to watch The Beach Boys
nobody cares about play
everybody laughed and then later bill
pulled me sudden he goes you didn't
really mean that did you
I was joking joking around man that's
something you would say yeah
yeah so hurt that I took a dig at my
for my money gummy bears are the most
overrated candy in existence for my
money most overrated candy in the [__]
out of here you said before this battle
that you could have defended gummy bears
how could you make that statement and
then say they're the most overrated
candy on the planet you know what I take
it back actually I've never purchased
gummy bears even I've only get them
through
the way you get an umbrella let me tell
you something about nerds yeah wait the
what the way you just inherit Gummy
Bears I don't know I've never purchased
them from my own on my own of my own
that's nuts that's nuts first of all I
have so much to say about them as a
child the discovery of gummy bears
changed my life I mean it was just the
cartoon was better than the candy I'll
tell you that you want to talk about
theme songs you want to talk about from
last week Friends The Gummy Bears
cartoon theme song is Everything the
gummy bear candy is the cartoon but the
cartoon has nothing to do with the candy
it's just same name but they're not
really but they're Bears they're gummy
bears sure but they're not related but
here and there and everywhere uh you
know it you know the song You know the
song though you know it Gummy Bear Song
how do you know that that's a very old
cartoon
no she wasn't
the theme song to The Gummy Bears
cartoon
Bears bouncy here and there and
everywhere High Adventures Beyond
Compare they are the gummy bear no
magic and mystery are part of it was
like a Smurf style thing they lived like
in a forest like a snork and they would
drink this gummy bear juice
gummy bears yeah but please tell you
what you got to say because I I have the
pros and cons for both camps listen if I
could if I had my druthers if I had my
druthers I would have but they're not
popular enough we have to go with the
most popular gummy candy which is Gummy
Bears if I had my druthers I would have
picked gummy worms gummy worms are were
I I honestly dude the Bears are the most
popular they're all the same exact [__]
they are hold on let me finish that let
me let me finish my point yeah
nerds once you get past
oh look there's two compartments
that's a day first of all the
compartment that's a game changer that's
a revolutionized boxing of candy and
especially marketing it to kids dude the
fact that you had your choice of two
different candies and you can close the
door and open the other one and that
also made it so that you didn't and you
shouldn't eat Nerds in one sitting some
people did they would just pour it down
but I like the fact that I could eat
some nerds get my taste a little while
later I have a taste of the grape I
switched sides I put it back in the
pocket I'm walking around with candy in
its own container it felt like built-in
Tupperware I love that you can do that
no I
I love the fact that they were different
sizes and I love the fact that sometimes
you got that with monster sizes the
Nerds no they weren't yes they were oh
yeah you had little ones big ones medium
ones and then sometimes you get the one
that was like the mother load they even
actors as a little
I didn't like that it bothered me that
the Nerds candy itself was in no way was
resembled the cartoon I disagree where's
gummy bears look like little bears they
look like little bears the nerds in the
Box look nothing like those things on
the bus
that's true I just said candy look like
pebbles yeah the things on the box had
legs well they need legs they look like
the M M's yeah the m m body looks like
an m m all right nerds look up right now
good
here's my point you for you to say the
fun name
those fun name and I'll tell you another
thing
we're in kids circles nerds might be
something that you get bullied about it
almost kind of made the word nerds cool
well I mean let's not give all the
credit to the candy company they were
riding the tales of uh Revenge of the
Nerds so I mean it was were they though
it was what could we call it
I don't think about it they look like
little [__] Pebbles
no they don't they've got arms and legs
they look like sperm you had to
amorphotize them whatever the [__] it's
called
I'm more my point is this the gummy bear
looks like a bear I like that in my
candy the Nerds are named after a Dr
Seuss book where one of the creatures in
the zoo
it's called a nerd I guess even better I
like it even more now I don't think that
that's true shout out Dr Seuss that
doesn't seem is that on Wikipedia yeah
according to a trivia person all right
please my point is this nerds were a
thing in the 80s it was it was it was
like saying WTF in the early 2000s it's
like it was it was it was part of the
the government business the same thing
it was it was part of the discourse it
was a you know I don't know gummy bears
no no gummy bears were a that was a new
thing we're gonna make this thing we're
gonna call gummy bears and they're the
cartoon came after the candy I'm saying
you just said that nerds were like a
thing in the 80s like gummy bears were
too you're missing my point I'm saying
you calling you you said them calling it
nerd them calling it nerds came on the
heels of the popularity of the term nerd
I said that in a time where a nerd was a
a negative thing attaching that name to
this candy kind of destigmatize it as
something I just thought that was
something I never thought about that was
kind of what I'm thinking and I think
and my point is Revenge of the Nerds did
that first like nerds nerds being cool
was a thing in the 80s like nerds might
have been out before Revenge of the
Nerds actually reading that uh in the
70s 1970s the word nerd was printed a
lot and became a popular
when did when did the candy Nerds come
out pimp
and who was it and was it a Willy Wonka
candy originally
Willy Wonka Factory 1983. 83. what year
did Revenge of the Nerds the movie come
out
I think it's probably like I think it's
80 45.
84. yeah all right take that and you put
in your pipe well I don't think that
they wrote and created Revenge of the
Nerds in the time since Nerds candy
dropped
but nerds was not based on Revenge of
the Nerds that's fine I know it is I'm
switching points yeah but
one thing that you do do is you you say
something
and there's no factual evidence behind
it and then we can go check it and then
you're wrong so then I don't think
that's a fair way of arguing I think you
should say I'm not sure about this but
maybe you know what but you don't and
then it's not revealed that you're wrong
until it gets tested and you know that
you're not sure about that but you talk
like you're sure and I think that you
have a long way to go in that sense when
we when we talk about stuff and I could
care less
I'm not going to change it I'm not going
to stop doing it I didn't think it would
I thought that Nerds candy came out
86.87 okay when did gummy bears come out
and I thought that Revenge of the Nerds
came out in 1981.
that's what was in my head gummy bears
by the way I know like Haribo is is a
big brand but is it 81 81 is it isn't
gummy bears like like it
they're not many companies make them
right they're not like it's not just one
like Caribou was the original as far as
like what does not is it not a patent or
something I no no I think there's I
think the I think the other companies
can't call them gummy bears they have to
call them like bear gummy or like okay
or like Bouncy Bears or something like
they give them different names I've
noticed but I think Haribo is the
inventor if I'm not mistaken
um and by the way you want to talk why
can I start talking about the gummy bear
the gummies now yeah but but try to beat
the test of time you see gummy bears in
every single gas station and rest stop
7-Eleven you still going through gummy
bears are still prominently featured I
don't remember the last time I saw a
true box of nerds I've seen nerd rope
here and there I'll tell you I'll tell
you I'll tell you because nerds you're
not looking for them and they're up in
the front under the counter probably
down low there's a package in a bag and
they're sold in an aisle and when you go
to look for other things that you
probably look for more often like
pistachio nuts or you know those [__]
dots on Candy they're right next to
those and so they're they're in you're
right in front and center buddy I'm
telling you I don't think they are I
don't think that nerds are still up
under that counter I look under that
counter you can still buy them I mean
it's not you know you know there there's
still a nerds still out yeah they just
showed the new packaging for sure yeah
wait what's oh that was new packaging we
were looking at with the little box
fairly new yeah that was that was and
they didn't abandon the box which I love
they also had cereal remember the nerd
series it was terrible right and it was
two different sides in the series and it
was just fine but that's something else
there might have been a gummy bear
cereal
first of all you get your gummy worm
your gummy shark your gummy anything at
all
they're all the exact same thing the
bear itself if you just if it wasn't a
bear and it was like gummies in just
like a little triangle form
it would be nothing without the bear it
would be nothing it would just be these
chewy they make nothing the texture is
god-awful no shut up it is I'd like a
texture of like a chuckle more than a
gummy bear first of all you put a gummy
bear in your mouth and you don't chew
that outer protective layer that bear is
going to stay in your mouth for two if
you put a gummy bear in your mouth your
saliva will not break the outer layer
and break that who's doing that you you
have to I literally have to chew and
feel my incisors ripped the bear apart
to get to that middle part which has a
little more flavor than the outside
which is coated in some like 3M like
protective coating and and by the way
when you get to the flavors
then they're not that tasty it's it
maybe Cherry not even dude it's a clear
one what's a clear bear what's he about
I don't know what flavor it is it tastes
good to me
you're crazy dude nerds only taste like
tart that's it that's it and for a man
that is a tax Sour Patch Kids nerds
taste like sour that's it they just
taste like sour oh let me get a bunch of
things I can almost choke on uh out of a
little box that that acts by the way as
a tool to most likely make me choke what
is the most what is the most possible
way for me to choke on this chokeable
candy put it in a little box and tip
your head back the box is part of the
power of nerds you can't you can't be
negative about the box I'm being there
you can't choke on a gummy bear dude
no because you're aware of a gummy bear
you chew it up you're aware of its
presence in your mouth
it's annoying you deal with a gummy bear
like steak it's annoying bro how many
times and then it gets stuck in your
teeth I said this before I don't want to
have to work for my candy and I want it
to work for it I don't want to chew half
of it and then it's whole torso which is
right wisdom tooth this is
this is why that's a good thing this is
why that's a good thing a gummy bear for
instance I'll get gummy bears bring them
into the movie theater once in a while
it's something that you can eat slowly
and enjoy over time like licorice for
instance nerds that you're you're out
dude we can all sit and pretend like we
would close the Box up we don't you
shoot it down twice you're done I close
that yeah
I close the box I close the box I'm
telling you outright that's serious you
close it once I've had nerds for days
I've had nerds for days I've had nerds
the whole week Monday to Friday I didn't
finish the Box because also they are
very strong okay
and I make claims that are true I would
have a nurse I would have a nerds in the
front pouch of my JanSport bag and I'd
have them throughout the week I know how
to ration that's one thing I like to let
me tell you something else that gummy
bears didn't have to do that nerds tried
to do and failed with the nerd's rope
that nobody cares about with giant nerds
which are disgusting what about giant
gummy bears hold on no there's a giant
gummy bear but it's a novelty action
giant nerds sugar free gummy bear and
tell me where that's your giant nerds or
a candy they tried to Market uh nobody
cares nerd cereal nobody cared let me
tell you about gummy bears they said
here it is that's what it is and that's
what you get and they have stood the
test of time they did not have to go and
diversify they didn't have to try all
these different things I honestly
believe they didn't even change the
flavor when they changed the shapes they
just said there you go that's what you
get
you sound like an old school comic
uh can can you name a a candy that you
think is underrated I want to put it up
I think gummy bears is I mean so
overrated I think gummy bears is the
most overrid it's boring it's so boring
you open the bag they're all stuck to
each other you peel off a green for [__]
the clearest for [__] the yellow what do
you mean I may be doing the orange and
the red but even then it's not a great
payoff you break it down you break down
the goddamn animal fat and the gelatin
and then you chew it it's a it's an
animal fat yeah the gelatin
I guess what do you mean yes all right
dude I take a little handful of Gummy
Bears I put them in my mouth it's a
fruit punch explosion
it's a variety of things without
smirking and they're great I mean there
are great kids a fruit punch explosion I
get it it's not actually it is an
underwhelming taste I disagree I get a
craving every few months for for Gummy
Bears punch explosion you have a Jolly
Rancher you have it oh Jolly don't even
get me started on a Jolly Rancher uh the
Jolly Rancher is the mo the most
passable candy that I would like meaning
I don't like eat it sticks to the teeth
I don't like it but I'm just saying I am
telling you every few questions I get a
craving for gummy bears that can be
shaded by one thing Gummy Bears or worms
and I eat it and I and I Barrel through
that bag and I love it
what
never free nerds sounds weird never for
nerds I can't
I can't be satiated unless they get that
gummy I don't think I have a nurse since
I was at least 14 years old like I can't
even remember honestly I don't think I
have either but I'm just I'm going back
to when these things might have meant
something to me and as a kid but another
thing is I think that old people might
like I don't think kids like gummy bears
I don't I never see a kid ask for them I
never see a kid eating them I I've never
seen like my nieces and nephews say they
wanted gummy bears or like gummy bears
it's a boring underwhelming candy candy
but underwhelming taste that is not
that's a little bit difficult to chew on
and it's nothing great the the
the ceiling of a gummy bear chewing a
gummy bear is so low it's so low I'll
give you that maybe maybe you could take
a while to chew them but hold on a
second sometimes I don't know what do
you mean people have gummy bears and
they say would you like a Gummy Bear do
you know that I say no
I do this more so that has never
happened to you I I promise I promise
you four out of five times I've been
offered a gummy bear out of five times
it hasn't happened five times
I'm telling you I I turned down Gummy
Bears I have no use for them who is
offering you gummy bears a person who
has them stop it what why stop it why is
that crazy that's not people have gummy
bears that's how you eat them
people I know this is such an insane
claim you don't think I've been in the
presence of someone who is holding gummy
bears
and I said no such an insane claim this
is such an insane claim when did that
happen
has anyone have offered you a gummy bear
no
maybe when I was 10 so so you've only
eaten gummy bears by purchasing them and
you own them and you only I'm sure the
movie I'm sure at some point in my life
when I was 10 years old somebody had
gummy bears and offered me some okay so
in the last 30 plus years someone hasn't
gone to you gummy bear no well no I
don't know what you had on a playground
what the hell are you doing I don't
understand no a movie who does this at a
movie I would say mostly at a movie I
got I got news for you I get my own
snacks at a movie I don't offer my
snacks to anybody around me and I don't
give a [__] if they offer me their
snacks I'm not interested what does that
have to do with what I just it's not a
team sport is my point and the only
place I could I guess you just told me
that I haven't been offered a gummy bear
and I also don't know anybody that gets
gummy bears at the movies to offer them
to me so I I don't know well you know
what you really have sometimes you have
a memory and sometimes you have no
memory it's selective sometimes you know
the person sometimes you never heard of
them
are you talking absolutely but you talk
like you're at the office and people
have Gummy Bears
I promise you in the last
I promise you in the last 400 months
someone has said to you would you like a
Gummy Bear what is how many years is 400
330 years you said you didn't happen
maybe when you attend Joe I don't even
give a [__] if that's never happened to
you I told you that I turned down gummy
bears went off to me nine times out of
two [__] that is true so you're saying
there's a frequency I'll tell you this
where there are two instances you know
why I said that because I I know I don't
like them and I don't eat them but I was
like there must have been a time where I
said okay so I gave it a 9 out of ten
but I really should have said I turned
them down all the time I don't like them
I I see no redeeming qualities with a
gummy bear they don't excite me I would
say it's more like one out of two two
times you've been offered these gummy
bears and one time you said no and the
other time you said yes okay so let's
use that as the accurate step but I mean
you're you're I you're talking like
people are walking down the streets
frequently holding sacks of gummy bears
offering to share them where did you get
that tell me the tell me quote me right
where did you get that remember the last
time I've even seen a person
eating gummy bears in the wild I just
told you myself
I told you most likely it's probably a
movie theater I mean all right fine
what's the big you're acting like and
and also nine times out of ten is a is a
vehicle to let you understand how you
frequency you're like ten times you
called me you called me out on my thing
that I do earlier I'm gonna call you out
on your thing you make unprovable claims
how are they that approvable I don't eat
gummy bears hold on a second no no let
me finish now let me do my assessment of
you yeah you make you make unprovable
claims
I've been offered Gummy Bears this many
times in the last two years and I've
said no I have no way of proving that
all I can say is is that sounds like a
poppy [__] to me I know but I didn't say
I've been offered this in the last two
years I just gave you a percentage nine
times that's at ninety percent take that
nine times it's still four and a half
times out of five whatever you want the
ratio to be I'm mostly and I don't feel
like that I just threw that in because
I'm like I had to have taken one one
time but my point is so I gave you the
one but my point is is you're using that
percentage to gauge a frequency and that
frequency sounds like it's two times
ever not every other week as if you make
it sound like this is how repulsive
these things are to be what did I say
that made you believe that I was
suggesting that I was offered gummy
bears every other week
the phrase every time somebody offers me
gummy bears that doesn't do anything
when the hell are you offered Gummy
Bears I don't I just don't
is the movie's not a good enough answer
it's like saying every time somebody
offers me snow caps it's like it's just
not a candy or a food people eating out
of the movies all the time it's my dad's
favorite candy we go to the movies all
the time all right
again you just said every single person
eats the nerds in one shot and nobody
uses the compartments is that not what
you're just accusing me of that's an
unprovable claim that's that's more
poppy [__] than anything about my
personal experience and you're telling
me what everybody else does yeah
I almost feel like I I think you know
that you know what you're saying you
know I I almost don't have to say you're
talking yourself into I think we're both
you're talking yourself into a hole here
but
right you're painting yourself into a
corner I think gummy bears are fun you
can take them out you can stretch them
you can play with them
they have a good flavor I like that they
last a little while tell me that when
you eat them tell me that when you eat
them you stretch them and play with them
you don't do they talk to each other no
I just said you make them [__] and
just pull on them I said you stretch
them stretch them yeah play with a
meaning like I do this so what happens
you like pull that pull like the head
off you bite the head off I told you if
they weren't in a bad shape they'd be
nothing they owe everything to the bear
everything I don't think that that's
what you stretch them if they were just
a square look gummy bears fall into a
great family of food that I don't think
gets enough respect the Swedish fish
family is part of this family don't or
Swedish Fish I told you you work for it
I don't like to do that but Swedish fish
is different than Gummy Bears I said
it's a family of candy way better than
gummy bear it's a family of Kent they
only need one they only need one taco
bro and by the way the fish is is nice
and detailed baby you want a gummy bear
is like somebody just like molded one
and it's like is it a bear I want to
talk about you want to talk about work
don't even sit here and tell me you
can't stand the work of a gummy bear but
you think Swedish Fish are better
Swedish fish is the most work on planter
next to a roller it's work Rolo you're
not you you why is a Rolo work the
caramel gets well Milk Dud is a better
example yeah milk dot I agree with you
but I'll tell you right now the uh the
the sweetest fish show is worth it it's
it's at the end of the day it's more
worth it than the gummy bear they
they're they're better they're more I
love this picture is soft actually when
you put it in your mouth one can melt in
your mouth and it doesn't take no it
cannot and no it cannot and when you
bite on it it oh it goes right away
you're not working on it like it's jerky
okay what the hell kind of gummy bears
you're consistency if you put them in
there in your mouth if you put a gummy
bear in your mouth
you can't deal with a gummy bear
gummy bears but if you put a gummy bear
in your mouth and chew it's it's the
terrible consistency it's tastes it's
enjoyable I think a Swedish fish is kind
of I Love The Ridges and the texture in
it right so let me film my mouth with a
thousand chokeable Pebbles and uh and
you can't choke on a gummy bear by the
way I didn't want to get into it but
they tried to do surgery and they almost
they almost went out of business you go
on Amazon right and we've done it before
go on Amazon right now put in sugar-free
gummy bears and read the reviews it
should be banned and illegal people get
literally their intestines drop out of
their asses one brand and one thing and
it didn't work and and that's it so they
don't do it anymore they did by the way
they brought out a new variation of it
that doesn't make people [__] they're
playing you got nothing to say about
that apparently we've talked to it Ad
nauseam that's something we're here to
attach that to this
that's not what we're here to argue diet
nerds and make people we're not here
there was no such thing as diet nerves
right that's what I'm saying but my
point is is sugar-free Haribo Gummy
Bears are a classic they've been around
longer they are more prominently
featured they are more often found in
your by the way you want to talk about a
road trip food gummy bears baby gummy
gummy candy is a is a road trip food
it's fun it's it's it's you know what it
is shareable even though I've never
shared it with anybody it's very
shareable now lean on the fact that it's
shareable very sure just said I don't
give a [__] sharing or anyone share with
me no one shares it I don't share it
I think when I think of it I like the
point
nerds are a selfish self-centered
experience you can close the serious
close the Box what I'm going to put my
mouth on the box you put your mouth on
it's disgusting you know right now it's
like somebody drinking out of the orange
juice container you know right now that
you are so full of [__] dude nerds are
made to tap out into someone's Palm with
that goddamn box it's the way you
deliver nerds to friends it's actually
again one of the pros in the mouth what
are you gonna do in a gummy bear you can
have someone remembers into the bag of
all 70 of them stuck together and ripped
remember when the Nerds box used to get
all the cardboard would get like uh like
like meals because you put your [__]
gross mouth on it you're gonna tap that
into my hand no thank you dude the first
time
the first thing you do in a box nerds is
open it put it into your mouth and go
whoop whoop that is the first thing you
do with a box of nerds yeah but you
don't have to put it up to your mouth
you can just tap them in oh yeah but
make it even more okay so when people
when people reach
and everything is stuck into one big
group of bear and they have to put their
fingers in and rip the Bears don't get
stuck apart I keep them I keep them
temperate okay
I keep them at a nice temperature
can't buy a bag of gummy bears that
aren't already stuck to each other
that's not true
to be true search your heart you know it
to be true
but I am in a decent climate okay
they're not [__] that you said you
can't share it's made to share dude you
like all right you know you know what
I'm saying about the mouth thing or with
the nerves put their mouth on their box
I would not want it yes they've all
and nothing nerds actually are meant to
be shared you should when you see nerds
everyone's always like want them and
then you just pour and you go like this
and you drop something everybody's
always like wants some
kids have nerds nerds are shared so
we're gummy bears when you're a kid not
really
stuck to each other you no kids no kids
doing that I mean my closing argument is
this gummy bears are part of a family of
candy that don't get enough love I will
put Swedish fish in that family I will
obviously put all the other gummy
candies in that family I will put
Chuckles in that family there is a
gelatin candy out there that gets very
overlooked and is an unsung hero in the
candy Market because they are holding
down a major corner of every convenience
store truck stop you ever go into you're
saying gummy bears are an unsung hero
they're one of the most happiest popular
candies they're all I'm saying that
family of candy the gelatin-based candy
that's another thing be nice if you
listen to me it's not original it's not
original everybody you make gummy
anything it's the same exact thing okay
they're holding it down no they're not
get you can get anything gummy any shape
gummy you want
you said at the top of this argument
immediately that I like gummy worms
better than gummy bears I said if I had
my druthers I prefer the worm to the
bear but the bear is the most popular
form of it it's the same flavor you
immediately but it's not a gummy worm
it's not a gummy bear and you
immediately said I choose something else
over the gummy bear
I just I'm arguing the Merit of the
flavor of the candy and the consistency
those two things are not different those
are gummy bears are a dime a dozen you
can get a gummy gelatin based candy
across 10 different kinds of Brands
across every you get the nerd is pretty
original as far as that goes maybe
sweetheart maybe a spree close to a nerd
something like that shouldn't charge
bite again another I'm saying spree more
more sorry Willy Wonka repackage that
flavor of nerd into so many different
candies that's why I took his name off
all this [__] became an embarrassment it
became an embarrassment after a while
all right The Gobstoppers tasted just
like nerds when they were out all right
there's so many of the Willy Wonka
candies tasted just like nerds wow
Gobstoppers they solo still probably not
because again they're a [__] choking
hazard this guy couldn't stop trying to
kill [__] kids with just people went
to the hospital went to the hospital
with sugar-free gummy bears went to the
hospital okay come on choking hazard
okay let's make a candy the size of a
marble that's by the way as slick I'm
not arguing Gobstoppers I'm just saying
everything this guy put his name on half
of it was
choking hazards
see your closing argument on Gummy Bears
versus nerds is everything that Willy
Wonka put his name on was a choking
hazard okay what is your closing order I
made my closing argument defending gummy
bears what is your closing argument
defending nerds I think nerds uh are
instant fun just by nature of the
packaging and I think they're more
memorable I think they're more unique
candy I think you're getting you know
two different flavors in one honestly
the gummy bear stuff like you don't even
know what flavor the clear is you know
and you love these you don't know what
flavor it is I don't know what flavor
any of them are to be honest they all
just meld into each other but but when
you put them together it tastes like
fruit punch but make your closing arms
I'm saying this I'm saying that I really
truly truly my heart of hearts believe
that gummy bears are one of the most
overrated candies in the biz I think
they're boring I think the texture is is
weird I think they don't pack a
flavorful punch like you said I think
they get stuck in your teeth I think
they're all stuck to each other in the
bag and it's not that fun it's not that
fun I mean not everybody sits there and
makes full acting scenes with the Bears
like you do uh and I think that the
Earth nerds is the opposite I even like
I even like the Moroccan Cha-cha-cha
when you shake the Nerds I shake the
nerds and I do a little jingle I'm
always shaking yeah I know she's walking
around shaking them in your hand like
you do whatever in the Box you don't
shake notes in the Box you don't shake
the nerves I haven't even seen nerds
since I was 11. I don't know I don't
know if I shake them in the box let's go
to the phones
uh one of the fans wrote uh at least
nerds you can eat when they get cold you
can't eat cold gummy bears what
do we not go to the phones last episode
it was too long wow oh man I would have
loved to have heard people's take on
that wait a minute you can't I don't
even understand freeze them maybe yeah
maybe nerds are gay than savocano
if there's an adult arguing for nerds
there's a good candy they need to be put
on a watch list well it's the nature of
this podcast site that I just I thank
you I toss that nerds were created to
satiate everyone's unconscious need to
eat a CR um aquarium gravel wow that's
fun that's fun I actually like that it
looks like aquarium gravel so that's a
plus for me also I love the person
that's coming down on someone for
defending theirs that watches the
podcast that's based on pulling stuff to
do that with funny
uh everyone's bringing up Nerds Rope as
um the happy medium of the two you know
I
I wish I could pull that in the art into
the argument but I didn't because I
don't know it well and I didn't want to
front
uh nerds are for babies gummy bears are
for adults
the Bears might take this one anybody
say anything funny
no I thought the thing was funny you
need to be put onto a watch list I think
that's funny
oh God don't be a sore that was like
because you can smell it special loss
coming
can you ask AI what they think is better
each time we do a battle
Won't Give opinions okay it will
probably tell us which one's more
popular okay
all right let's give the win to the
watchlist comment who is that follow
uh
uh at
battle alpaca
spell It Beat battle
b-a-t-t-l-e-a-l-p-a-c-a okay I I um I
think gummy bears is gonna win because I
think it's a more popular candy
I wonder how close it is I I think you
might be doing like a 65-35 situation
the reason I said I was surprised is
because I didn't expect this much nerds
hate
I thought it'd be a little more okay but
anyway 11 000 votes okay
drum roll Humble Pie let's get that pie
up there the winner with 64
is gummy bears wow dude you called the
number yeah thank you thank you I still
love you bud love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to